hi everyone I'm David Griffin and I'm
Michael Medina here to bring you a
review of video game called child of
light it's made by Ubisoft Montreal you
know BB saw is very French French
Canadian French a video game company
make some really good tiles i believe
the writer the real child of light also
wrote far cry 3 which know you and I are
both fans of huge guys behind the
assassin's creed franchise eventually
what's coming out watch dogs watch dogs
it's coming out so Ubisoft big company
but you know this whole new console race
you know there's not a lot of big Triple
A games out but last year my kind I
really surprised her video game of the
year review a lot of these smaller indie
game will call him indie games no
they're made by a huge company are taken
over really had storytelling very
creative storytelling and this game
child of light is about a young princess
named aurora Lucy's Austrian and she
awakens this world where this which has
stolen the Sun the moon and the stars
you know all the light has gone her
mission should she choose to accept it
is to reclaim the light basically she
was looking for a day I think her mom's
already dead and it's just really a
beautiful game it's almost like
watercolors away and say gorgeous were
your first impressions of on playing
childhood first just the visuals you
know absolutely this is fifteen dollars
this is not a six dollar games no no
it's an absolutely gorgeous and and
that's the thing too because I know we
talked about this a lot too I mean
triple-a titles they're not going
anywhere on but it's just it does seem
like the focus is kind of shifted at
least slightly more towards these
independent games they're like brothers
or games like that you've got um the
guys that are behind Bioshock oseroff
you're gone all back and yeah focusing
on smaller titles and stuff which is a
good thing because then you get gems
like brothers or gems like this game
yeah I like again not just the visuals
but like it's a straight up pretty much
like you know JRPG yeah yeah so if
you're forgetting the holes right even
if you're not it's really easy cuz like
I just played for the first time just
last night yeah and I'm not yeah I like
JRPGs but not biggest fan right yeah but
I mean it was pretty easy to connect
thank you you're one year our battles
and I really didn't
much time I mean you know give it a
couple fights and start figuring out the
the mechanics and stuff and then you can
pretty just go from there but I probably
played maybe a good like you know 30 to
an hour really summer run there and I
thought the story was very engaging yeah
you know so it really offered a lot more
substance than just those visuals which
is what's gonna really get you right i
mean aurora looks great she's just you
know I guess call her you know cute
little girl and kiss her hair's just
constantly flowing in the background and
she has her sword it's like when you win
a victory like she'll lift or sort up
like this but it's so heavy it just like
topples over like even when she swings a
sword she swings us or like a little
girl holding a big weapon which I feel
like so do this but just put all
overweight just like falls flat on and
what's nice is because I'm JRPG I like
final fantasy you know JRPGs again I
think they're getting a little dated in
my opinion I wish they'd kind of a
develop a new system but this game is
very friendly you know this is first of
all it's made by a French company so
it's friendly it's pretty easy just to
jump right into if you're not from
leaves that turn beats like oh no it's
turn babe don't be turned off by that's
I don't think it's that difficult to get
me no not at all and um going back to
what I said about games like this or
like brothers and stuff it is very
refreshing to see this type of
creativity yeah going into games like
because that's the good thing it's the
benefit of like these smaller games
because you can take risks yeah you know
a game like brothers would never be a
triple a title no take a chance on a
game like that so you know you put it
out for like 15 bucks whatever give it a
chance like it took me a little while to
get on board but once i did i'm like
blew me away yeah and i think that's
what's gonna happen with this game i
think we're gonna be one of those games
i don't want to say it's flying under
the radar because people are talking
yeah and it's Ubisoft so they've been
put behind the scenes of the day loans
in years exactly but I think it's
definitely gonna be one of those games
that's like you know a lot of people are
gonna probably give it a second you know
I don't know if want to get rich or not
because of like the content or like it
would not give it a try yeah Rama she
won't be disappointed that's cool i mean
it's this little girl i mean if you like
fantasy if you like epics I mean she
wakes up she thinks she's in this dream
like she it the dialogue is funny so all
the conversations I don't know if it's
true i am at bent ammeter but it's all
like rhyme every other you know lying
rhymes basically and it's it's kind of
goofy took this kind of bed don't worry
but order that charm there's a little
girl your world so it almost feels like
you're playing in a dream right yeah i
mean it's kind of like what is like this
fairy tale so where I mean everything
just really add sitting just kind of
that goes with the whole tone right
everything that works that's gonna tell
I know we didn't quite get there last
night but I got there I played a little
bit more and there's a part where you
actually get the ability to fly I know
you've seen it probably the videos like
and the flying is really cool we just
kind of sword you can kind of go all
over the map and I mean it's just fun
it's it's a game that's interesting it's
inventive yeah it's the colors it's
really every scene that you're in you
want to like take that like snapshot and
like put it on your wall is like a ping
app so gorgeous and and like I said I'm
going back to what like gameplay wise
and just now ease it is to play you do
get like this little buddy yeah they
cause they call him mr. firefighters a
funny thing he'll be like hey actually
have a name but I don't know his name
yet I guess he learned that on later but
yeah but if it's cool because he does
play a huge part than the actual you
know fighting mechanics and stuff so
like when you do get into a fight you
can kind of hover them over your enemy
slow down shine a light on them which
slows your enemy down which gives you an
opportunity to kind of like attack so I
just thought little things like that or
just create and just add to the the
charm and the quirkiness of this also to
again with any type of big fantasy game
like a JRPG or even like game like
Skyrim it's like the menus can be
intimidating this menu is very simple
yeah really get skills you get gems
which give you more power but like the
skill that the map the charge pretty
easy it's like you want to increase
damage you want a new ability it's
really easy to now get it is very simple
yeah and even like the actual scene like
the battle scene yeah that screen and
stuff that aren't a bunch of knows a
little a little bar at the bottom yeah
that's all it is it's like you're up top
you had amis on the bottom it's pretty
easy to figure they can slow your enemy
down with your little Firefly guy and
then if you can beat him it's all once
you get you use
to it exactly it's pretty easy to do so
again don't get turned off by the JRPG
stuff yeah very easy to pick up after a
while you'll get it fast so let's I
guess in wrapping this up let's think
about rating this game you're going to
do the same scale that we do for our
movies here so go on maybe an F to an A+
and just see I mean just on first
impressions and playing through it I
mean so far i would give it give it an
a-minus i think it's fun i love the
visuals of the visual style the story
isn't you know super deep but I mean
it's fun it's a little fairy tale and
yeah I'd give it an a minus um I
probably get a good b-plus these lessons
good be pleasant just because again
turn-based can be a little dated and
that's why I think some people because
of that might be turned off and is issue
that like whole system would actually
sitting there waiting to go I think that
even though like we may be saying give
it a try I know people still give it
because that is kind of an outdated
system is either you love it or you
don't right yeah exactly um but again it
is fun it is pretty it's easy to play so
it could be plus those are good so
you're a minus b plus that's a vote of
confidence right there go pick it up
it's on i believe all the systems on pc
xbox one xbox 360 ps3 ps4 $15 even get
on my math is awful you can get for
those kind of games for sixty dollars to
the cost you have major triple-a again
it might not even be good that's true so
go ahead and give trial I'd the child of
light a try try out an indie game
support indie development in the video
game community we need it and as always
you can come chat with Chavez that think
hero calm share your opinions with us
estimate you think a child of light or
what you think of after our review if
you use like might interest you we're
also on this youtube page at think hero
pro be sure to give us a like subscribe
comment you know we always looking back
to your comments when we can and we're
also all of us are on Twitter dennis
michael myself i think here is where we
all are i'm at griffin de nom at mr.
michael Alexis we also have a Facebook
page that's facebook.com slash think
your fans be sure to like you know make
sure you spread the word social media
and yeah we'll be seeing you guys soon
you